five seconds
welcome everybody to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee a bit of
housekeeping fire alarm procedures if
the fire alarm is activated please take
the stairs down to the reception area
and out of the building to the green
Hawley Square which is the assembly
point please do not use the lifts
officers will assist you in advice when
it is deemed safe to return to the
council offices this will benefit
ing no
um restrictions use of mobile phones
would everyone please unpleasant please
ensure that mobile phones are turned off
or to silent while the meeting's in
progress any apologies for absence we've
got an apology from Roshan era for
absence today
um any Declarations of Interest no
Declarations of interest
um so agenda item number three is
application for variation to a premises
license at the Botany Bay Hotel Marine
Drive broadstairs I call upon Miss
Phillips the council's principal
litigation system to explain to the
party is the procedure that we will we
take and join the meeting
thank you very much good morning
everyone
um as was said we're here to consider
the application for the variation of the
premises license at Botany Bay Hotel
Marine Drive Kingsgate the application
is made by Shepherd neem Limited
for variation of the premises license
which is Ln forward slash two 200 501
361 I'd like everyone present to know
that the decisions made by the
subcommittee are made in accordance with
the licensing act 2003 and based on the
information that's presented in this
agenda so there's no predetermination
everything that's said will be
considered carefully we are here we will
hear the parties in the following order
we'd hear the licensing officer the
applicant and the respondent making
representations and each party has up to
15 minutes to make your rep your
presentation you don't necessarily have
to go up to 15 minutes but that's the
time allotted to you to have the
subcommittee
um the applicant the representative and
interested party you may ask questions
after each representation is made the
hearing shall take the form of a
discussion led by The Authority so
there's no cross-examination it's not
like a court process
there is no limit to the questions that
could be asked
um at the end of the proceedings each
party has about five minutes to make a
closing statement and of course that
would be based on the representations
that you've had
Etc
um and then the representations will be
made in the same order after the summary
of the statements the hearing will be
adjourned to allow the subcommittee to
deliberate the subcommittee members and
myself as the league officer and the
clerk will remain in the chamber
and usually the deliberations take up to
about 30 minutes and then everyone is
called back into the chamber to hear the
decision and the licensing hearing
regulations
um do not necessarily give a time limit
for the deliberations but it's usually
about 30 minutes
and that's the procedure for this
morning's meeting
it's great thank you
um
um with the licensing technical support
team manager please present the report
good morning everyone we received an
application from Shepherd name for the
Botany Bay Hotel to A variation for
their current license they receive
planning permission to have an outside
bar and increase their decked area and
the planning permission limits use to
the bar till the hours of 11 till nine
o'clock each day
um as the applicant advertised it we
received one representation which is
before you in the agenda we did not
receive any comments from the police
Environmental Protection Team licensing
officer or the fire service thank you
thank you
um
you have any questions
um for technical support manager
the Africa applicant that's you
um if you would like to um
present your application
and also you're happy for me to just
read out
the the thing so um
we we would like to address the concerns
of the objector to the license variation
for the Botany Bay hotel we will also
aim to outline the application in more
detail so our application is only for an
outside bar survey and the rationale is
that the outside bar will alleviate the
pressure on the inside bars which in
turn creates a better environment for
those guests staying at the hotel
the application was advertised in line
with the licensing act 2003 regulations
both on site for 28 days and in the
local newspaper
we have offered three conditions in
respect of installing extra rubbish bins
and signage and offering recyclable
glasses to anyone outside we have
received no objections from any of the
responsible authorities which includes
the planning department
so to address some of the points that
that were that have been raised is that
we do not feel the insulation of an
outside bar would cause a significant
increase in customers or that anyone
would make a special Journey to the site
because it was there customers will
still be able to use the outside space
with or without the bar in the way that
they do now as the current license
allows for off sales and on sales
we're not aware of any complaints or
antisocial Behavior today and as
previously stated neither the police nor
environmental health have objected it
would also be the case that the outside
bar would be manned by staff who would
effectively be managing the area and
monitoring customer Behavior currently
it is difficult to do this from inside
the building
Last Summer the site operated an outside
Bar for a short time by way of tens and
it was General and it generated no extra
rubbish noise or antisocial behavior
that we are aware of
therefore the site has proven that it
can run and control an outside bar and
the customers that use it
the outside bar forms part of a wider
development which will provide a large
amount of seating outside therefore
customers would not need to leave the
area and sit elsewhere
the grass area referred to in the
objection is an area of open public
space people can buy food and drink from
any outlet and still sit there
unfortunately we cannot control this but
we can ensure that customers act
responsibly on our property
so in conclusion we feel that this is a
proportionate application that does
consider the local area and residents we
have offered the following conditions
reusable cups and glasses will be
available for customers sitting outside
or taking drinks away the outside bar
will be manned at all times when open
and to close by 9 pm and additional bins
to be placed outside along with science
advertising guests to respect the area
and we very much hope that the above
will allay the fears of the objector and
show that we are responsible operators
thank you very much
um
do you have any questions for um
uh well I went down there yesterday and
I think as you've moved the beer garden
over from where it was it was near uh
Residential Properties so I think what
you've done is an added bonus and
I think that'll be better for the pub
and the fact that it's away and it's not
going to encourage any more people so I
don't have any objections
thank you I've read through I'm the
objection and the report and um Shepherd
memes a good operator I don't actually
have any questions
does the technical support manager have
any questions no do you have any
questions for the
um technical support manager no
okay thank you very much with the
exception of the subcommittee members
the Democratic Services officer and the
principal litigation solicitor please
can I ask those questions leave the
chamber so the subcommittee can come to
decision you'll be invited back for the
decision to be announced
thank you
I'd like to now invite Miss Phillips and
specification sister to read a summary
of the subcommittee's determination
thank you in this application for
variation of the premises license at
Botany Bay Marine Marine Drive
Kingsgate which is made by Shepherd neem
limited having heard the licensing
officer I haven't heard the applicant
and considered the representations that
have been made it's the decision of the
subcommittee to Grant the variation of
the license to include the new outside
bar with the same hours as is in your
planning permission
thank you okay thank you Jennifer that
concludes the proceedings to this
licensing subcommittee today thank you
very much
[Applause]